bit by bit agriculture waste is shoveled
into a boiler powering this Factory in
Northern India the unit next door is
using natural gas both textile plants
have been running on coal but after the
government announced a ban on polluting
fuels beamrana spent a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars to switch over he says
his operating costs have doubled
our industry is unable to compete it's
much cheaper to dye textiles in cities
like Surat Punjab is still using pet
Coke the industry here is grieving we
are thinking of Shifting our factories
to other regions
the region around New Delhi is one of
the most polluted in the World Air
remains toxic despite several efforts to
reduce it now authorities have banned
industries from burning polluting fuels
it's also illegal for people to use coal
in their homes according to government
data the region uses 1.7 million tons of
coal every year industrial emissions
account for about 30 percent of the
pollution this ban is aimed at reducing
them and also phasing out dependence on
fossil fuels the high cost of switching
to alternative fuels has forced some
businesses to shut down while some are
moving to areas where coal is allowed
others are planning to sell and recover
their investment we are living hand to
marriage we are struggling to repay our
loans people here are desperate I'm not
the only one suffering we even
considered protesting but business
people don't want that
is on the committee that recommended the
ban she says it's the only way to drive
change every citizen is convinced that
present path of development is not
sustainable and therefore they have to
adopt cleaner Myers the only problem
today is do they have the money
I am not in favor of subsidies but may
be a sort of soft load thermal plants
are exempt from the ban many business
people reliant on fuel want the
government to ease restrictions or give
them financial support to make the
transition
Northern India